so getting your first users it's really
important right and you just have to do
everything and anything that comes to
mind and whatever you think will work so
in our case we put up this landing page
and I started emailing my friends and
when they started using it and you know
rooster is about sharing and people were
helping one another out the moment we
got these first stories off someone was
able to borrow something borrow a bike
from a friend and someone was able to
find a language exchange in English to
Chinese language exchange when we got
those stories I knew that those are
really heartwarming so I just went to
the local press in Palo Alto to Palo
Alto online and Palo Alto weekly and
like look this is happening it's really
local and look at all these amazing
stories and I was able to get a story
out so that brought another few hundreds
of people and my friends invited their
friends we tried things that are totally
not scalable like with printed postcards
and we went and put them in people's
houses and door hangers just anything
anything to get those firsts a few
hundreds of users and to prove to
yourself that they want it and that
they'll use it to start your first user
base just figure out where your users
hang out where they do it is it offline
is it online if it's online that's great
maybe there's a forum where they all
just hang out maybe it's all the moms
forum maybe it's the small business
forum maybe it's the accounting form
whatever your space is figure that out
and go there and be active and approach
them and tell them here's my thing I
just started it will you check it out
you know a lot of startups do that in
places like hacker news and read it and
and those are their type of communities
but maybe it's a different type of
community for you so just go there put
it out there you know be there just be
very authentic about who you are don't
try to advertise just say look this is
who I am
I've started this startup I think you
know it can be useful for you and I'd
appreciate your feedback go sign up I
think people will respond to that better
than if you try to you know post
something very pompous about I'm
changing the world and you should all be
on this because you really haven't yet
so just be authentic common mistakes I
see startups
I don't do or kind of like a
misconception that they have is that
marketing is something you can hire for
right you build your product and you get
the marketing person and they will just
make the product grow
and actually marketing is inside the
product it's a core part of it and
marketing is the language that you use
in your product it's the flows you have
in your products it's the social
elements you have in your product it's
the incentives you give people to invite
others to your product so marketing the
product person should be a marketing
person or the marketing person you hire
should be there from the get-go and help
define the product when you're just
starting out and you don't have a budget
don't think about how you can grow grow
grow to millions and millions and
millions just think about how you can
experiment and perform the largest
number of experiments to see what will
work so kind of take the pressure off
trying to get a million users tomorrow
and see how you can get to users and get
those two users to bring two more users
and if that experiment has been
successful maybe and and it's something
that's replicable then now maybe you
have something so just think small try a
lot of things and figure out what works
so to grow your user base from 0 to
1,000 the first thing that I would do
the first thing that I did actually is
understanding what makes my user tick
where are they spending their time what
are they doing there I mean in the what
are the what are the apps that they are
using what kind of website they're going
to what are they doing on those web on
those web sites and apps
what what's interesting for them what
what are their habits what are the what
are the social platforms that they are
using and start focusing on those places
you can do everything everybody wants to
do everything you can you can do
incentives and SEO and social and and in
offline presence you need to know
exactly what's working and what's not
and double in in what's working so for
example let's let's let's assume that
you're doing a QQ word research for your
SEO but one of the byproducts that isn't
that you're getting from keyword
research is understanding your audience
interests what they care about what are
they asking Google when they're trying
to find something online what kind of
apps are they using what are their
habits
and when you're finding out what
people care about you can start
strategize your your next your your next
plan you can start understanding watch
what you need to do the important
question is how we from zero to just a
hundred thousand views a day over a
hundred thousand to a billion views a
day how do we get from zero videos
uploaded to a hundred videos uploaded to
a thousand videos uploaded and that was
sort of the summer of 2005 we went out
there to a lot of different forums out
there and told people that if you needed
to use a method as a server to be able
to host your videos use this as the free
place there are there's you know we
don't charge storage fees we don't
charge any fees for the you as a host to
be able to upload your videos just
upload the content or will do all the
transcoding and we'll do all the
bandwidth we'll pay for all the
bandwidth for you for all the views that
you want to use the site for so that was
really what I think that in the
beginning but there was another part of
it was you know MySpace in 2005 was one
of the largest users or largest sites
out there that utilize this ability to
be able to host videos and so they
themselves didn't have a service to be
able to host videos their users were
desperate for a way to be able to upload
and share videos and incomes YouTube
with perfectly every time you uploaded a
video on to YouTube there was this
little snippet at the bottom you just
you barely have to scroll down at all
and here's the copy and paste and you
can add this copy and paste HTML snippet
unto everywhere so we allowed you know
pretty much any site that allows HTML
snippets eBay Craigslist but myspace was
one of the big ones where people were
seeking out this solution and we
provided the solution I think the
equivalents as well the differences
between I think different companies
different startups but key metrics and
how do you actually get that I think
with YouTube it was about giving sort of
almost free bandwidth out and
accumulating more users getting the
brand name out there for PayPal was
different right it was getting the
people's trust and it was trying to get
people to see this as a way to make
payments online what people were still
back in
Time 1999 this is something they've
never heard of and they were still kind
of trying to feel out what the Internet
can do and so one thing that PayPal did
early on was to be able to sign a very
high value I think that when we were
looking at banks out there and every
customer had sort of a value about $750
and so when PayPal took a look at it and
said well it only takes us ten dollars
to get a new user it's it's an
investment that we're making that's very
costly now but the returns on it years
from now will be very big and so it was
a signing for every new user that you
would create every new user account
automatically gets $10 and to their
PayPal account they can start making
payments and then to try to create that
virality to try to to try to create more
users and get you are automatically
connected and comfortable with this idea
of payment - payment service it
automatically gave you $10 for every new
user that you brought online but you can
quickly see that once you start getting
your first thousand users and they're
actually getting another 10,000 users it
starts accumulating very quickly that
you're actually just paying out all of
the funding that you're getting from VCS
and checks to these people but
ultimately it's it also created a
network that people were comfortable
with and down the line people it became
harder and harder to get that $10 so
initially it was you would sign up for
the account and confirm your email
address and here's $10 in your account
later on it became you have to give us
your credit card information and then
even later on it was you have to give us
your AC at your banking account
information and then you would get $10
and by that point I think if you're
giving if you're a new user that's
actually giving credit card information
as well as your banking information it's
well worth the $10 to get that
information one of the questions that I
get a lot from sort of new entrepreneurs
whatever they like give a talk for
example and I get questions coming up
afterwards and it's kind of of this kind
of model of question which would be I
have this great idea and two things I
think one of them is I've been thinking
about for a long time
but I don't know what the next step
should be and I think the obvious is you
know why don't you start it and it's
like well no I don't know if it's gonna
work and I'm still working on something
else at the time and it's taken up a lot
of my origin but at the end of the day I
think behind every company there was
that risk and there was the ability to
say forget it for six months three
months for a year I'm gonna go without a
salary and without that sort of safety
net and I'm going to take a chance and
I'm going to take some risk to be able
to see this through but without ever
taking that risky first step
no company's ever been created so I
think I think that's one of the key
things there I think the second one is
always this question that people come up
and say well what do you think about
they would pitch this idea and they
would say you know but one of the
reasons why I'm not so ecstatic about
starting this is that I don't see this
as a billion dollar company and I I have
to say I don't think that when ever one
of these companies whenever Facebook
started or PayPal or YouTube started I
mean we've talked earlier YouTube is a
dating site we didn't think YouTube was
a a billion dollar company I think as
long as it's an idea that you believe in
it as long as it's an idea that you sees
you know either yourself or somebody
being you can see and visualize the
users behind the site then create it
because people will come and it's gonna
be a question as to how many people will
use the site but I think that's more
important rather than trying to create
something that you think is going to you
know rather than having to qualify the
the actual startup idea with is it going
to be this billion-dollar idea I think
it's more important just to say is it
creating a solution to a problem that I
can see